how do you know how hard you're actually
working out TomTom's multisport
HRM gps watch monitors heart rate for
any aerobic distance activity running
swimming cycling or just the treadmill
or spin machine if you're not braving
the elements other watches do similar
stuff but the TomTom is lightweight and
less bulky and the large display makes
for easy viewing even with sweat pouring
down your face the menus are easy to use
and an included bike mount lets you
track speed in distance while cycling
Plus unlike other wearables it's
waterproof up to 165 feet good for
swimming or showering you can link the
data to apps like MapMyFitness which
syncs with tom-toms gps so you can
monitor speed and track your routes now
all you have to do is put in the sweat